I have a very old computer for my rife. I think it's a Windows 7 that I got from you about 15
years ago and I started with you. Should I replace it? It seems to be working just fine.
No, you shouldn't replace it. Quite honestly, some of those old computers back 15 years ago
were better quality than the ones you could purchase today. I have a number of people that started
with me 15, 20 years ago that are still using the Windows 7 computer that came with their rife,
and it still works, which is a testimony for a little laptop. So don't you don't need to replace it,
don't just keep going with it. There's no reason to replace it. I think every single person
I've updated their program to be a true rife now. I've updated their program to be version 6 or
version 6.4, which is you don't need anything beyond that. Still have some people that are still
not in version 5.5, but it's working just fine and it's working with their program to
find that they've been in remission for 15 years, so I don't think we need to change anything.